die bundesregierung richtet wegen des
corona virus einen krisenstab ein in
nordrhein westfalen müssen hunderte
menschen zu hause in quarantäne bleiben
war der anschlag in hanau und der tod so
vieler menschen zu verhindern der
innenausschuss des bundestags fragt nach
den hintergründen und im streit um
saubere luft sagt das
bundesverwaltungsgericht selbst wenn der
eben grenzwert überschritten wird ist
ein diese fahrverbot kein muss
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und haben schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert könig für
den sport auch von mir die sorge vor dem
corona virus wächst die bundesregierung
geht davon aus sicht dass sich das virus
auch hierzulande weiter ausbreiten wird
die lage habe sich deutlich verschärft
sagt innenminister seehofer in den und
gesundheitsministerium haben einen
krisenstab eingerichtet sein ziel
ansteckungskette zu durchbrechen
dazu sollen ab sofort frühzeitige tests
schneller klarheit bringen die kosten
dafür müssen die krankenkassen
übernehmen und reisende die aus den
besonders betroffenen ländern wie china
japan südkorea iran und italien nach
deutschland kommen müssen den behörden
ihren aufenthaltsort melden wird jemand
positiv getestet kennen die behörden
durch solche aussteiger karten alle
mitreisenden und wissen wer sich
möglicherweise angesteckt hat gabriele
handelt berichtet trotz der vielen
warnungen sich erst einmal telefonisch
zu melden sie kommen doch die menschen
die sich krank fühlen und fürchten mit
dem corona virus infiziert zu sein
die unsicherheit ist groß deshalb hat
die bundesregierung einen krisenstab
eingerichtet mit dem ziel die
bevölkerung zu schützen und das virus
einzudämmen
jeder angeordnete test wird nun von den
kassen bezahlt
wir haben uns dabei darauf geeinigt dass
es wichtig ist dass im zweifel einmal
mehr auf das virus getestet wird als
einmal zu wenig das also es am geld
nicht scheitern darf
der gesundheitsminister hat die
bundesländer gebeten ihre pandemiepläne
zu aktualisieren was heißt das konkret
dr frank marx kennt als rettungsarzt die
notfallpläne
sie regeln beispielsweise wie man
plötzlich viele infizierte auf
schwerpunkt kliniken verteilt
das fängt also bei organisatorischen
maßnahmen an wie zum beispiel die
bereitstellung von material die
festlegung von orten wo menschen
hingehen können die betroffenen sind und
endet
letzten endes in der frage wie arbeiten
den behörden so zusammen dass man
optimal arbeiten kann
reisende die mit flugzeug und bahn
zurückkehren sollen nach dem willen des
krisenstabs so genannte aussteiger
karten ausfüllen
das hat vor allem den sinn für den fall
des auftretens einer infektion aus einem
flugzeug aus einem zug zurückverfolgen
zu können wer war mit der infizierten
person in diesem flugzeug bei allen
schutzmaßnahmen geht es darum die
infektionskette zu unterbrechen
damit es nach möglichkeit nicht zu einer
pandemie kommt deutschland ist dem virus
nicht schutzlos ausgeliefert das betonte
der präsident des robert koch-instituts
heute nochmal alle könnten etwas tun von
banalen dingen wie händewaschen bis zum
meiden von großveranstaltungen dort wo
infektionen gemeldet wurden es gehe
darum zeit zu gewinnen und die
ansteckungswege einzudämmen
was das bedeutet erleben im moment etwa
300 menschen in nordrhein westfalen die
zu hause in quarantäne bleiben müssen
florian kojak die kappensitzung in
gangelt vor knapp zwei wochen auf ihr
war das ehepaar das mit dem corona virus
infiziert ist
rund 300 weitere karnevalisten nahmen
teil und weil sie sich angesteckt haben
könnten müssen sie nun erst mal zu hause
bleiben in quarantäne
auf den strassen heute gespenstische
leere alle schulen im kreis heinsberg
bleiben geschlossen auch die kitas sind
zu eine stadt fast lahmgelegt
die leute versammeln
das infizierte ehepaar wird aktuell im
klinikum düsseldorf behandelt
der zustand des ehemanns ist weiterhin
ernst er leidet an einer schweren
lungenentzündung der erste deutsche fall
mit so einem gravierenden verlauf das
robert koch institut die bundesweit
oberste behörde für
infektionskrankheiten warnt
und 15 das hieße also 15 von 100
erkrankten schwer
das ist viel und nach den zahlen die wir
bisher haben
muss man davon ausgehen dass etwa ein
bis zwei prozent der menschen die
infiziert werden sogar an dieser
krankheit sterben und immer neuer fälle
werden bekannt jetzt auch der erste in
rheinland pfalz im westpfalzklinikum in
kaiserslautern ist ein junger mann
positiv getestet worden er hatte sich
selbst eingeliefert dieser mann war bis
vor kurzem noch im iran hatte dort
kontakt mit menschen die auffällige
symptome am harten fälle wie diesen ganz
genau beobachten und so das virus so
lange und so gut wie möglich eindämmen
absolut sinnvoll und notwendig betont
der fachmann mit jeden tag oder jede
woche die wir dieses geschehen
die ausbreitung verlangsamen können
steigt die chance dass ein therapeutikum
zur verfügung steht auch deshalb ist es
so wichtig dass sich die menschen wie
die im kreis heinsberg an die quarantäne
regeln halten dort vor ort ist thomas
münten für uns thomas halten sich denn
die menschen an die quarantäne
die meisten halten sich augenscheinlich
daran man kann das nicht genau
kontrollieren das wird vom kreis
heinsberg nicht bei jedem kontrolliert
es handelt sich allerdings um eine
behördliche anordnung
das heißt wer sich nicht an die
quarantäne hält begeht eine
ordnungswidrigkeit und muss quasi mit
bußgeld rechnen
aber dadurch dass die leute hier so weit
verteilt sind es sind ja nicht nur leute
aus gangelt auf dieser sitzung gewesen
lässt sich das eben gar nicht so einfach
kontrollieren
wichtig ist dass man dafür gesorgt hat
dass für die ungefähr 14 tage die so
eine quarantäne im schlimmsten falle
dauern kann
die versorgung der leute die zu hause
sind gesichert ist das wird über die
nachbarn geregelt über die familie
geregelt aber auch die
hilfsorganisationen sind da im boot und
versorgen die von der quarantäne
betroffenen patienten dankeschön für
diese informationen auf granit thomas
münten war dass auch andere länder
greifen zu massiven sicherheitsmaßnahmen
japan mit derzeit 200 infizierten eines
der risikogebiete schließt bis ende märz
seine schulen ein weiterer risiko herd
liegt mitten in der golfregion in iran
hat sich die zahl der offiziell
infizierten allein heute fast verdoppelt
auf mindestens 245 mit 26 toten beklagt
das land die meisten corona opfer
außerhalb chinas phase berichtet
mittlerweile weiß jeder in iran dass die
lage ernst ist züge busse bahnen werden
desinfiziert großveranstaltungen
abgesagt täglich werden die zahlen von
infizierten und toten nach oben
korrigiert die menschen versuchen sich
zu schützen viele sind verunsichert
uns fehlen die nötigen informationen und
viele schutzmittel sind kaum noch zu
finden
bis vor kurzem gab es masken im
überfluss und heute sind sie wie vom
erdboden verschwunden
das gesundheitssystem in iran ist
relativ gut ausgebaut doch krankenhäuser
und apotheken leiden unter
nachschubproblemen zwar hat die
us-regierung die wirtschaftssanktionen
für medizinprodukte heute gelockert
trotzdem wächst die angst in der
bevölkerung ein parlamentsabgeordneter
behauptete allein in der stadt kommen
seien 50 leute am virus gestorben
dieser mangel an transparenz ist
furchtbar niemand präsentiert
nachprüfbare aussagen das macht alles
nur noch schlimmer
wo ist parteipräsident rooney versucht
das volk zu beruhigen versichert man
habe alles im griff doch mittlerweile
sind auch einige seiner
regierungsmitglieder und parlamentarier
erkrankt auf einer pressekonferenz am
montag zeigte sich vize
gesundheitsminister arrietty schwitzend
und husten und musste tags darauf
eingestehen dass er mit dem virus
infiziert sei ich werde meine aufgaben
per telefon aus dem krankenhaus
erledigen und ich verspreche euch es
wird mir in ein paar tagen besser gehen
dann kehre ich zurück um euch zu dienen
auf bald auf wiedersehen als wenn die
krise im land nicht schon schwer genug
wäre
so trifft jetzt noch das virus ein volk
das seit langem bereits im
ausnahmezustand lebt
wenn sie fragen zum gruner virus haben
können sie die auf heute.de stellen um
20 uhr 30 sendet dort heute plus im
livestream eine sprechstunde mit dem
chefarzt einer lungenklinik gute eine
woche nach den tödlichen schüssen von
hanau galt es heute in berlin möglichst
viel darüber herauszufinden was genau
wann geschah und vielleicht auch warum
der generalbundesanwalt informierte auf
einer sondersitzung den innenausschuss
des bundestags über das was die
ermittler wissen und auch das thema
waffenbesitz kamen ausschuss zur sprache
florian neumann berichtet die
sondersitzung beginnt mit einer
schweigeminute
dann will der innenausschuss wissen
warum der mutmaßliche täter nicht vor
der tat gestoppt werden konnte er hat
sich wohl beim generalbundesanwalt im
november mit schreiben gemeldet und da
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie gut
aufgestellt sind sicherheitsbehörden das
schreiben liegt dem zdf vor eine
strafanzeige gegen eine unbekannte
geheimdienstliche organisation die ihn
angeblich seit geburt überwachen
19 seiten die damals noch keine
rassistische gesinnung erkennen lassen
viel mehr psychische probleme besitzt so
jemand waffen ein abgleich mit den
zuständigen behörden rechtlich nicht
möglich datenschutz der innenminister
denkt nun über eine verschärfung des
waffenrechts
nach müssen wir in solchen fällen dann
nicht dafür sorgen dass der waffenschein
entzogen wird wo begründete zweifel an
der zuverlässigkeit einer person
bestehen
der innenpolitische sprecher der fdp
beruft sich heute ebenfalls auf diese
strafanzeige und sieht keine
rassistische tat der mann hatte keine
gesellschaftspolitisches urteilsvermögen
mehr auch wenn er zielgerichtet in
seinem wahn gehandelt hat dabei hatte
der mutmaßliche täter noch vor dem
anschlag ein manifest im netz
veröffentlicht eindeutig rassistisch
genauso die auswahl seiner opfer
dementsprechend scharfer widerspruch von
allen anderen fraktionen
ich halte es für unerträglich dass von
der rechten seite dieses hauses aus der
fdp-fraktion das geleugnet wird wir
sehen eine ganz klare mitverantwortung
auch der afd
zu möglichen mitwissern der konkreten
tat heute keine angaben die ermittlungen
laufen nach new york der
un-sicherheitsrat thema ist wieder
einmal der krieg in syrien außenminister
maas hat den syrischen machthaber assad
und russland kriegsverbrechen im
nordwesten syriens vorgeworfen während
wir hier sitzen sagt maaß fürchten 3
millionen zivilisten in idlib um ihr
leben
krankenhäuser und schulen würden
bombardiert 950.000 menschen sind nach
uno angaben auf der flucht vor den
truppen assad und vor den bomben der
russischen luftwaffe straßenschlachten
schüssel verletzte auf den griechischen
ägäis inseln sind proteste der einwohner
völlig eskaliert ihre wut richtet sich
gegen den bau neuer flüchtlingslager
wegen der nähe zur türkei sind lesbos
samos ziel vieler menschen die nach
europa wollen
allein im kampf moria auf lesbos hausen
derzeit rund 20.000 menschen fast
siebenmal so viele wie das lager
eigentlich fassen kann
die insulaner sehen ihr zuhause vor dem
kollaps andreas postel berichtet
keine lage auf den inseln zu
demonstrieren sie auf lesbos auch heute
mehr als 1000 bewohner protestieren den
zweiten tag in folge gegen den bau neuer
flüchtlingslager wir sind für alles
bereit
ich will dass bessere tage für die
einwohner kommen und ich glaube daran
dass wir das auch schaffen
seit tagen kommt es zu zusammenstößen
zwischen aufgebrachten insulanern und
der bereitschaftspolizei wie hier beim
manta modus mit straßensperren wollten
die bewohner den baubeginn des neuen
lagers verhindern
die bilanz 43 verletzte polizisten zehn
verletzte anwohner
es ist ein dilemma wegen der unhaltbaren
zustände soll das lager moria
geschlossen werden neue lage auf den
inseln wollen aber auch die migranten
wir wollen von dieser insel weg wenn wir
weggehen wird es auch keine probleme mit
den einheimischen geben
wir verstehen die bedenken die sorgen
der griechen griechenlands regierung
kündigt heute an die grenzkontrollen
größtmögliche maß zu verstärken
ich habe bereits die minister für
handelsschifffahrt und den leiter der
küstenwache angewiesen die anzahl der
schiffe und die anzahl der patrouillen
auf den inseln der östlichen ägäis
erheblich zu erhöhen
begründung der schutz vor dem corona
virus von den grenzkontrollen während
vor allem die menschen betroffen die
über das meer kommen zurück nach
deutschland die zahl der verkehrstoten
ist im vergangenen jahr auf einen neuen
tiefstand gesunken insgesamt starben
3059 menschen im straßenverkehr 216
weniger als im vorjahr und so wenige wie
noch nie seit beginn der statistik vor
mehr als 60 jahren
den stärksten rückgang gab es bei
tödlich verunglückten motorradfahrern
minus 15 1 prozent bei den e-bikes
dagegen stieg die zahl der tödlichen
unfälle stark an um 32 6% auf 114
todesopfer
in mehreren deutschen städten gibt es
inzwischen diesel fahrverbote doch über
die verhältnismäßigkeit solcher
maßnahmen wird immer wieder diskutiert
vor allem dann wenn grenzwerte nur knapp
überschritten werden oder gar zu
erwarten ist dass sich die luft in den
städten verbessert
das bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig
hat heute ein urteil zur reutlingen
gefällt felix zimmermann berichtet
reutlingen in baden-württemberg eine
stadt mit dreckiger luft die
stickstoffdioxidbelastung liegt seit
zehn jahren über dem grenzwert
trotz der krankmachenden luft gibt es
keine diesel fahrverbote dies liegt an
einem gesetz das der bundestag letztes
jahr auf den weg gebracht hat eigentlich
müssten wegen der überschreitung des
grenzwerts von 40 mikrogramm in 45
städten diesel fahrverbote verhängt
werden doch nach dem neuen gesetz sollen
fahrverbote erst ab grenzwert 50
verhältnismäßig sein
danach werden aktuell nur noch vier
städte von fahrverboten betroffen
das bundesverwaltungsgericht entschied
heute das gesetz sei rechtlich
wirkungslos auch bei geringen
überschreitungen dürfen fahrverbote
verhängt werden
die deutsche umwelthilfe begrüßt das
urteil des fahrverbots verhinderungs
gesetz der bundesregierung des krachend
gescheitert failed man hat gedacht man
könnte sich dort an den europäischen
grenzen machen das hat das gericht nicht
akzeptiert allerdings urteilte das
gericht auch wenn die grenzwerte bald
unterschritten werden weil die luft
sauberer wird sind fahrverbote
unverhältnismäßig so kann auch ein
höherer grenzwert
ein höherer grenzwert überschreitung
vorübergehend hinnehmbar sein wenn die
grenzwertigen kürze sicher eingehalten
werden können
reutlingen könnte deshalb um fahrverbot
herumkommen
doch in allen städten in denen die
einhaltung der grenzwerte nicht in sicht
ist müssen nach dem urteil des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts diesel
fahrverbote verhängt werden
damit sind wir beim sport beim fußball
genau aus der königsklasse am grünen
tisch kämpfen sie gegen den europapokal
ausschluss für kommende saison auf dem
grünen rasen läuft es für manchester
city im achtelfinale der champions
league gewinnt das team von pep
guardiola das hinspiel bei rekordsieger
real madrid mit 2
21 es winkt die runde der letzten acht
kevin de bruyne mann des abends im
bernabeu-stadion real ohne auf den auf
der bank sitzenden toni kroos nach einer
stunde mit der führung durch cisco
manchester aber überlegen und nach
vorarbeit von der bräune mit dem
verdienten ausgleich durch gabriel jesus
in der 78 minute nach diesem foul an
sterling der siegtreffer durch elfmeter
kevin de bruyne sieben minuten vor dem
ende eröffnet für manchester sid die
beste chancen aufs viertelfinale
zumal ramos wegen einer roten karte in
der 86 minute nach einer notbremse fürs
rückspiel gesperrt sein wird
überraschung durch einmal hin zu pauline
grabosch und lea-sophie friedrich bei
der bahnrad wm in berlin
das schnelle deutsche trio feiert gold
im team-sprint im finale gegen die
favorisierten australierinnen bleibt
dass emma hinzu im duett mit grabosch
vorbehalten den entscheidenden
schlussspurt anzusetzen
die deutsche mannschaft knüpft damit an
die erfolgreiche ära von kristina vogel
und miriam welte an christopher roth er
führt zur halbzeit des männer
wettbewerbs bei den skeleton
weltmeisterschaften in altenberg ein
zwischenstand mit dem auch die experten
nicht unbedingt gerechnet haben er ist
die ganz große überraschung christopher
roth er als nachrücker spät ins team
berufen ohne einen einzigen weltcup
einsatz in dieser saison und dann die
führung nach zwei läufen bei den
weltmeisterschaften die geschwindigkeit
die ich das ganze jahr nicht hatte habe
ich irgendwie zu wiedergefunden und
heutige leistung einfach auf den punkt
gut am start auch gute leistungen
restzeit geschoben also so wie es
eigentlich sein soll dann zum höhepunkt
und sogar ein deutscher dreifacherfolg
ist möglich gerät er führt vor alexander
gassner und axel jung und das
europa-league-spiel salzburg gegen
eintracht frankfurt ist wegen einer
orkan warnung auf morgen 18 uhr verlegt
worden
auch für deutschland warnt der deutsche
wetterdienst im schwarzwald und im süden
bayerns vor orkanböen und dann beehrt
und seitdem machte tat noch jemand mit
dem wir gar nicht mehr gerechnet haben
im saarland macht er vor allem den
autofahrern jede menge probleme und dann
haben wir noch eine meldung zum corona
virus nach erster meldungen gibt es in
nordrhein westfalen 14 neue fälle
neuinfektionen mehr dazu sich gleich im
heute journal um 21.45 bianca heißt das
sturmtief das gerade über süddeutschland
zieht was das für uns und morgen
bedeutet erklärt gleich katja hoppe hier
ist morgen christian sievers dran danke
für ihr interesse wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren schneesturm
tief wie janka hat uns bereits erreicht
und verabredungsgemäß hat es in
rheinland pfalz und im saarland schon am
vormittag geschneit
im laufe des nachmittags schneit es dann
auch im sauerland im taunus und auf der
schwäbischen alb dieses schnee sturmtief
zieht im laufe der nacht mit großer
geschwindigkeit über bayern und baden
württemberg weiter ostwärts dabei geht
im südwesten der schnee wieder in regen
über und das liegt am starken bis
stürmischen südwestwind dieser
südwestwind der wird mit seinem sturm
fällt auch richtung osten abziehen und
so sind windgeschwindigkeiten in
süddeutschland von 100 bis 120 kilometer
pro stunde möglich vor allen dingen in
den alpen nördlich von oberpfälzer wald
odenwald und hunsrück merken sie von dem
wind wenig dafür aber umso mehr von dem
schnee denn bis morgen früh breitet sich
eine geschlossene schneedecke in bayern
aber auch in teilen von sachsen
thüringen und hessen aus von alldem
merken sie in dieser nach themen
nordosten wenig glatt kann es allerdings
überall seien bei temperaturen um den
gefrierpunkt morgen liegen die
höchstwerte zwischen 1 grad im vogtland
und 10 grad am oberrhein
die letzten schneeregen und regen fälle
ziehen ostwärts ab dann wird das
freundlich sonne und wolken wechseln
sich ab der samstag bringt dann mehr
regen und milde temperaturen
danach geht es wechselhaft weiter
schönen abend noch